good morning chaps have you seen how
beautiful it is along that Chesterfield
Canal it's absolutely stunning today and
the weather is
perfect for Brick laying and laying
concrete so we're going to tackle this
section this morning I hope you can see
that it's looking rather dark isn't it
there we are how's that so I must have
knocked a setting on the camera so what
I will do in a moment is just pause the
video and uh sort this camera out but
yes we are going to start laying the
concrete and the brick sections down
here uh and in order to complete
that then I've had to go and purchase a
particular piece of
equipment so yes we made the investment
and we've picked up this little
beauty so Chan is here just been helping
me assemble
it uh look at that £19 from screw
fix and well we'll have a better look at
her in a
sec there we go we got the white balance
fixed
so yeah we picked her up this
morning uh she is
134 L concrete mixer it says on there
I've always known them as a cement mixer
we've just literally assembled it took
me about 25 30 minutes
and well that's a fired up she's whisper
quiet whisper quiet so we're going to
drag around the corner get some of this
sand
and I've got some ballast and whatever
else on the back of the
van just there some cement and we'll
start the cementing
process so we've got a first mix in on
the new fraking
machine seems to be working all right if
I'm honest so uh this is basically just
uh sand cement no in it I'm just going
to put a very small Foundation down for
the little wall the retaining wall for
the uh the herb garden at the back there
and then once that's done we'll mix
ballast in with this maybe uh one part
cement one part one and a half part sand
and uh two parts
ballast and that should give us a nice
concrete for laying down as a pavement
for the Dr roll
got there in the end I've also got a bit
of plasticizer somewhere so we'll pop a
bit of that in as
well oh
God even plastic tubs come in plastic
bags these
days don't know what they're
[Music]
thinking oh
yes there we go
so we're a fair few hours into the day
and we've basically got the wall
built uh it's good enough for me it's
going to be painted so I'm not too
worried about the SM smudging of the
cement on the
edges uh so now for the last hour of the
day we're just going to lift lift these
slabs up here Dot and Dabber laying back
down and then when we come in with
concrete uh tomorrow or the day after we
can just
pour and fill in the gaps down the sides
that's what we want to do get rid of all
these weeds growing down there and we'll
fill all that in with concrete and
cement it's nearly home time
buddy it's nearly freaking home time so
it's going to be a slow day on the Vlog
today because we've been busy just
getting that job done we're anticipating
deliveries
tomorrow and uh we want to really make
sure that those slabs were down and sort
of gone off before the drayman walk over
them with cask and keg full of beer I
send a Shivam his spine so uh we've just
plowed on with it and I didn't really
get chance to pick the camera up more
than a couple of times so I apologize
for that uh
but I'll show you what we've
done so the mixer cleaned put away
worked an absolute
treat and
then if we kind of just shoot through
here we'll be able to have a
look all the slabs that we've got laid
down so these have been relay and reset
they're solid now we're going to pour
concrete down the
sides and put some of these Quarry
stones in there
to TI all up and then that is the brick
wall finished was a bit awkward on these
Corners here and here but what we can do
is lose a bit of that Rubble in the
bottom level out that section there and
then yeah we've got this great big wall
so
initially I was
thinking growing hops up there and then
I changed my mind and I wanted a big
logo up there and then I looked at how
expensive the logos
are you know to kind of get like a
street artist to come in or something
and paint on
there so I'm toying with the Hops idea
again now cuz I think well there's a lot
of space as you can see so at least if
we put some hops in there they're going
to be rigorous enough to actually cover
the whole wall you
know so we'll see if anyone's got any uh
named hop rise hes any Cascade or
shinook or east K Golding even would be
nice um I'd appreciate a few rise homes
uh I'd be willing to pay Postage and
whatever else if people were selling
them like FIV for half a dozen rise
Helms something like that let me know uh
and if I can get them cuz it's going to
start to sprout very soon if not already
if I can get them in the ground we might
even get some Hops at the end of the the
year so I'm just going to pop the camera
back on the tripod and uh wrap it up for
today don't go anywhere quite yet so
yesterday I put a post on patreon
telling everybody over there that we're
going to do a tasting test for the New
England IPA because I don't think it's
turned out as it should I think it's
overly bitter
in fact I'm almost certain it's got
overly
bitter and uh today was going to be the
day where we'd had it saged and vented
and we're going to try it out of
Cask we've been sidetracked a little bit
with uh the concr in the new car the
cement mixer all these things that we've
done today which I know I didn't film
much of it I I regret it but it's
difficult because obviously we've got
Jack the Lad under my wing now and kind
of have to get him uh set up with jobs
because he's only 18 and he's learning
so I can't just
say uh go and get those 15 casks mate
Costick them and uh sanitize them and
fill them up with beer out of that tank
every step of the way I have to show him
what to do so it's going to be obviously
it's a it's an apprenticeship
essentially it's training up of somebody
who is uh who's a novice and because of
that um my work days have become a
little bit more hectic so I've not been
able to concentrate as much on the Vlog
don't worry it's obviously just going to
be a little glitch you know a blip if
you like so um Stuart also forgot to
stillage the beer so it's not all on my
back but he's gone and done it tonight
so
tomorrow when we get to work or when we
finish I'll make sure I take the camera
and to the seller and we'll give that
New England IPA a
whirl but I don't want to leave you guys
without seeing me drink a beer because
freaking know that's what it's all about
isn't it so here I am with a northern
monk New World IPA India paleale and the
reason I've got this is actually
because the best before
date was the 4th of
March so can't sell it in the pub I'm
going to drink it at home woo 6 and 1/2%
baby 6.2 Down the
Hatch it's still good foring see you
tomorrow
[Music]